well if you have an appointment to get
what is now your second covid vaccine at
the las vegas convention center
a warning you may need to wait in quite
a line today people really surprised
when they had to wait
hours for their appointments once again
joe moeller there live to tell us
what is causing joe all that backup
well it was a long day for folks here if
just about 30 minutes ago somebody from
the health district here came out and
actually took the line that was out here
inside to get that second dose well
yesterday there was an issue with the
wi-fi which caused a delay in
registration
well today we asked the health district
what was wrong today
they said it was just simply busy
obviously we would have liked shorter
lines people getting shot number two
were surprised thursday
i was told there was no wind wednesday a
technology issue caused long lines
thursday the health district says that
wasn't the story
they say these lines are due to so many
appointments and walk-ins
it's worth the wait it's once we got it
it's fine you know
we expected lines we stopped by cashman
center where the first doses are
happening
it appeared business as usual at the
convention center they are now limiting
walk-ins as some people were waiting up
to four hours
i'm not happy whoever put this together
did not do it right
you can't have appointments like this
and these people
seniors over you know older people
standing out here
that's ridiculous chuck luby says he
showed up two hours early and is glad he
did
well with the technology today you would
think it'd be far more advanced
he says despite the line the weight is
worth it loopy's wife who was battling
cancer contracted copen 19 and passed
away
in december everybody's lost somebody
hearing this the whole time
and the sadness it's all around
hopefully this year
we'll get rid of this
and now back out here live we also did
ask the health district today what is
being done to
improve this process they say they are
working on it some sort of solution
to make this simpler for people
reporting live here at the las vegas
convention center john wall 8 news now